welcome to this video playing its n zu :
right
hmm I always have problems to
differentiate this okay so let's let's
do a French oh it's taking its time as
well really unmoved to d3 d4 Knight c3
Knight f3 Queen e2 yeah
b3 even yeah this is getting slightly
weird lips
really let's check briefly if they're
not disconnected or something no ok the
advance always played with Bishop d7 hmm
yeah here Black has got more than one
interesting move f6 is the sharp one
came from going for that the alternative
is to play a c4 with a very positional
closed game here
black is trying to try to really fight
against the center but wait essence
isn't see one hanging C takes D 94
okay spotted that now unfortunately
unfortunately okay but now this helps my
development okay so if I take C three
now it probably yeah it speeds up his
development and night B fire is an
immediate threat room hmm
so should I am should I ignore this not
take the pawn but it's a bit of shame
yeah really yeah come on it's a it's a
bomb mmm what you know maybe Bishop to
e7 and what Bishop d6 I'm running
straight into Knight B 5 and a 6 mm I
would love to play a 6 but he's got he's
got Bishop g5 then it's a bit bit
annoying a Bishop to c5
yeah this is too too ambitious
probably Bishop c5 or not
if he goes before them
yeah come on I'm burning time here like
no tomorrow and this guy is just
blundering a central pawn and I'm
burning time okay so should I just play
94 now on Bishop t4 it's not too bad and
I'd be five okay so let's let's speed up
him yeah this this is what I had to had
calculated actually and thought that
should be okay I'm keeping the extra
pawn him and hopefully I'm annoyed yeah
he's got some compensation this is clear
two bishops
covering h7
you know turn wise I'm not in great
shape but it's it's still it's so
feasible maybe we can take and take two
six seven as possible it's not possible
okay so um what's now yeah probably
oops oops I need to activate him and
prevent ug3
it takes twice I've got Bishop c6 and
activated the bishop
maybe this is still alright yup he's got
quite serious compensation yes but I'm
not sure about this the bishop on g6 is
not it's not a bad piece as well it's
not clear that age five age six and yeah
age six and Queen f5 is what I need to
do
covering h5 and getting Rupert III in
the mix not sure why I played h5 you
know maybe it six what is success am
hanging potentially Bishop c7 or
something
hmm really okay
getting this activated should help my
course some ways unchecking them I can
go here 27
ah what deck
this is really really tough to play yeah
maybe he can go Queen d6 I'm not quite
sure what I'm playing after that
time morning I'm just I'm just hanging
the rope I didn't see it great great
yeah okay yes gotta be five and this is
probably enough
check check check check
no and mate black what the complicated
position yeah I have no idea what was
going on here you have the compass on
zero zero zero we know that kind of
stuff yeah rook e8 better for black but
okay who is going to going to see all
that yeah my king is of course very weak
I've got I've got counterplay we're but
very very very tough to plane yeah this
is this is good for good for black and
this is of course I just blunder I can
just take the rock yeah
yeah and it was very tricky after I took
the pawn this is stupid I can just take
the bishop of course I had the knight of
course I can just take this why didn't I
do that because yes this this is just
excellent for black kids this is stupid
yeah this is like ten times better than
the game here white has got really
enormous compensation llamar this white
is better
probably yeah okay white white is better
here no doubt about that
he's got the huge initiative and they've
got this this really awkward Bishop and
did a pretty good defensive job at first
but then it was just too much okay
thanks for watching